all right so next up we have John Miller
talking about social cost offices
tradition classification hi I'm John
Miller and I'm a graduate student here
at UC Berkeley and today I want to talk
about the social cost of strategic
classification and what I hope to do
today is to kind of elucidate some of
that negative costs are kind of hidden
externalities that are associated with
common solution concepts that the
community has been using around problems
in strategic classification so this is
joint work with Smith and le Alka jargon
and my adviser Moritz right so before I
launch in to kind of our high-level
critique of strategic classification I
want to start just by illustrating what
is the project or the problem of
strategic classification with a few
examples so imagine that we have an
institution here like a bank that
decides to classify people about or for
something that they might care about say
whether or not this individual here Bob
receives a loan so typically in machine
learning we have a dynamic that looks
something like this the individual
applies for a loan and in this case
suppose he's rejected for a loan now
normally in machine learning this is
where the problem stops but in strategic
classification we're gonna elucidate
another dynamic that goes on so Bob
remember it cares about whether or not
he receives the loan and so suppose that
Bob then decides to manipulate his
features or change himself to make it
more likely that he'll receive the loan
subsequently so maybe he opens a few
more credit cards or perhaps he moves
apartments and changes a zip code or
even just increases his net worth all of
which maybe make him a little bit more
creditworthy in the eyes of the
institution so consequently when he
applies again he's accepted I want to
illustrate this is by no means kind of a
hypothetical example so there's a very
recent paper that illustrates that a
large number of people when they're
exposed to their FICO scores over time
subsequently kind of engage in these
sorts of behaviors and you see an uptick
in their credit scores so this kind of
dynamic is ubiquitous in the lending
setting but it's not just in lending and
I'm going to talk about another example
which I think nicely illustrates what
happens in in these sorts of strategic
or interactive settings and this is
comes from a great paper by Camacho
Conover in 2012 so I want to talk about
in in 1994 the government of Colombia
decided to use a sort of classifier to
determine eligibility for a host of
social programs the specifics of exactly
like what the classifier is or how st.
Peter aren't particularly important but
the salient feature is that based on
things like household income demographic
characteristics etc they construct
something that they call a poverty index
score which ranges from zero to a
hundred and the important thing is here
this threshold right at forty seven
which will illustrate with the red line
denotes eligibility for a host of social
programs whether or not people can
receive a social benefit so in nineteen
ninety four when this is first rolled
out you get kind of a nice bell-shaped
curve around the poverty index score and
the threshold picks out a particular
quantile of the distribution three years
later in 1997 we see roughly the same
picture the distribution still is nicely
bell-shaped the thresholds picking out
roughly the same quantile but then in
the summer of 1997 something interesting
happens the government reveals some of
the information that goes into
constructing the threshold and into
constructing a score and as well as
reveals the eligibility threshold and
you see a different phenomena observed
obtained so a year later in 1998 you see
you see a sharp discontinuity right at
the threshold of 47 so people that were
just above the eligibility for social
programs start to kind of manipulate the
score and go below it and then a decade
later in 2003 the measure is basically
useless where a large fraction of people
are not below the score and this is
generally the dynamic that happens in
strategic classification so in a
nutshell will say that the strategic
classification problem is as follows
when classification is used to allocate
scarce resources whether that's whether
or not an individual receives a loan or
whether or not they receive some sort of
social benefit they have an incentive to
change themselves to maybe apply for
more credit cards to increase their net
worth to manipulate their responses on a
survey in order to receive a positive
classification so what I want to do in
this talk is that normally when we think
about problems in strategic
classification we take a relatively
institution centric view normally we
focus on how do we find something like
Stackelberg equilibrium which will
maximize the institution's accuracy
after accounting for the strategic
behavior instead what I want to focus on
and I want to elucidate some of the
human costs associated with strategic
classification and in particular the
question that I want to explore is how
do institutional efforts to improve
strategy robustus affect the people
classified so just a sort of roadmap
we're going I'm gonna start out by kind
of thinking about how look what this
sort of strategic adaptation looks like
how we should think about it and then
I'm gonna return to this trade-off in
this tension between the institutional
accuracy on the one hand and that people
who are being classified and adapting on
the other so when thinking about
strategic behavior and strategic
adaptation I think it's really important
to have a clear idea of what exactly
we're talking about because in different
contexts this can indeed look very
different so to illustrate this I want
to use an example from the domain of
health insurance so in the last few
years a number of health insurance
companies have started offering
incentives to people for kind of wearing
a step counter and achieving certain
exercise goals every day and if you
reach say a certain step count you
receive a lower insurance premium
so just for illustration suppose you're
somebody that's a little bit below the
step count you need for today in order
to get your lower premium there's kind
of two different ways in which you could
think about how they might manipulate
their attributes yes there we go you're
yes I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a third
one which i think is still pretty good
so the first one is that you can you can
pick up trail running you can start
exercising you hit your step count also
because you're exercising you become
healthier and actually the insurance
premium it's like maybe make sense that
it's lower you can also purchase one of
these fantastic machines
the Chinese Internet is a wonderful
place and they have all sorts of great
ways so basically you can shake your
step counter every day on your desk and
I think there's kind of a key difference
between what's going on here and what
I'm going to call like on the one hand
like the trail running and the other
hand kind of this like amazing Chinese
contraption is the difference between
improvement and gaming so what I'll call
improvement is basically altering the
decision rule or alternating the
decision by manipulation that changes
the underlying label so you should think
about like actually exercising to reach
your step count or actually increase
your net worth to improve your
creditworthiness and the kind of thing
that unites a lot of these sayings that
these for the most part have positive
effects like you if you exercise more
you're actually healthier maybe you're
actually also creditworthy if you have
an increase in net worth on the other
hand though I want to contrast this with
what we're gonna call gaming and so
gaming is altering the decision by
manipulating proxy features without
changing the underlying label so think
about opening unnecessary credit cards
that are kind of unrelated to whether or
not you're actually going to repay your
loan and the salient point here is that
most sorts of gaming is sort of
unjustifiable or pointless effort like
as a as a help like public health
specialist you wouldn't recommend the
intervention to increase like health
outcomes to just shake your iPhone on
your desk and what I'm gonna try and
argue on the next few slides is that
this is really like the default case in
machine learning is it most of the time
we're not deploying classifiers that
incentivize improvement but are actually
something that is more liable and almost
invites gaming and I'm gonna do this by
thinking about this from a sort of a
causal perspective and I want us to
think about partitioning the features
that a classifier uses into two types so
on the one hand we have causal features
on the other hand we have anti coastal
features and to return to our lending
example we should think about something
like the causal features being things
like net worth which are upstream of
creditworthiness and the anti causal
features being things like the number of
credit cards someone has open which are
downstream of creditworthiness and I
want us to think about separating or
partitioning gaming and improvement into
different categories based upon how one
manipulates or intervenes on the
different types of features in this
graph and so I think I'm gonna argue
that improvement
is sort of manipulating the causal
features in this graph if you manipulate
or intervene on a console features like
net worth it actually improves your
creditworthiness the other point here is
that usually when you intervene on the
causal features you'll preserve
classifier performance if the classifier
is just using those causal features
gaming on the other hand which would
think about is manipulating the set of
antique causal features so if you
increase an intervene on the number of
credit cards at that point it's
unrelated to the underlying
creditworthiness and so you're not
actually improving anything and
particularly because now you treat
you're changing the distribution or
you're breaking down these sorts of
statistical correlations when you are
manipulating or gaming the ante causal
features you're also going to degrade
classifier performance okay so I'm going
to argue that machine learning is
usually in the case where we see gaming
and not improvement and the reason being
is that most machine learning systems
are anti causal so there's a great paper
by shukoff in 2012 which could does a
big meta-analysis of kind of how a lot
of machine learning looks and most of
the problems that we're trying to solve
are usually in the antique also
direction and in some sense this is sort
of the way in which prediction was
designed to work and if we think about
domains like lending in some sense
increased use of machine learning has
actually led us to even use more anti
causal signals so typically if you think
about how FICO scores may be worth
there's at least some causal factors
involved maybe your net worth or whether
or not you have a savings account but as
we see people use machine learning to
say predict whether or not you repay
your loan based on your mobile.phone the
features that we start to see are things
like the number of outgoing calls the
text response rate the end time balance
all of which are kind of easily game a
bull and always going in the antique
console direction and kind of the
evidence for this is that decision rules
do indeed degrade under manipulation
pressure and so it's sort of this is
usually encapsulated and what people
call good hearts laws so that once a
measure becomes a target and people
start trying to manipulate it it no
longer becomes a good measure so they're
things lose its predictive accuracy I'm
gonna argue just that the ubiquity of
good hearts law is sort of evidence for
the fact that most of the time we're
working in the antique causal direction
consequently like what's the upshot of
all this is it strategic adaptation to
machine learning systems is often gaming
not improvement now why does this matter
and I'm gonna argue this matters when we
start thinking about how certain choices
about how we choose to account for and
adapt to strategic behavior
might incentivize more or less strategic
adaptation and if most of the adaptation
we see is gaming that improvement we're
kind of incentivizing or encouraging
more of this pointless or unjustifiable
effort
okay so now that we've sort of laid out
the high-level problem of strategic
classification and talked a little bit
about what type of strategic adaptation
we expect to see in the face of machine
learning systems I want to return to
this question about well how do
institutions typically defend against
strategic behavior or at least how does
the computer science literature suggests
that they defend against them and to
illustrate this I'm going to use a
simple binary 2d classification example
so on the one hand we have the positive
instances in the green and on the other
the negative instances in red so if
we're not accounting for gaming we'd use
something called the non strategic
optimum which is just a nice hyperplane
that nicely separates the two so if you
have strategic behavior you'd expect
some of the negatives that are close to
the decision boundary to jump across it
and obtain a positive classification
consequently most approaches to solving
the strategic classification problem try
to do this by accounting for the effect
of this strategic behavior in advance
and so what they do is they seek to find
something like the stackelberg
equilibrium which knowing that the
negative individuals are going to try
and cross the decision boundary they'll
try and shift the boundary up a little
bit more away from the negative
individuals then the important thing
here is that when we play the
Stackelberg equilibrium and when you
think about these solution concepts we
also expect some of the positive
individuals to also cross the decision
boundary so if we think about this
picture on this on the screen right now
in some sense this is kind of like the
perfect case for the strategic
classification framework that before in
a non strategic case we had 100 percent
accuracy
now with the sacral burg equilibrium and
the strategic setting we still have a
hundred percent classification accuracy
but the point that I want to argue is
that this way of thinking about the
world is very is still institution
centric in particular the institutions
happy either way but we didn't account
for the fact that the positive
individuals in this case still have to
game to get across the decision boundary
and they say argued before most of the
time that we're thinking about machine
learning we're thinking about this sort
of like gaming and not improvement
behavior so this in some sense is like
pointless or unjustifiable costs on the
positive individuals
all right so now that we've talked into
just a high-level instead of a
qualitative level about some of the
trade-offs you might expect I'm gonna
dive in a little bit more deeply and
talk slightly more precisely about the
trade-offs that we can show in this
model so just what some we're on the
same page I'm going to illustrate kind
of the basic framework that we're
working with in strategic classification
and as I mentioned before we have two
parties you have the institution on the
one hand and the individual on the other
individuals are endowed with some
initial state features X which you
should think of as a vector and RD a
label which is binary 0 1 and
importantly they also come equipped with
a cost which basically tries to capture
how expensive it is for an agent to move
from their initial state to some new
state and this cost might not just be
monetary costs it could also be
opportunity cost so I think I kind of
want you to think about this cost is
broadly everything you would have to do
in order to change to the new state now
the institution on the other hand will
just have a classifier a binary
classifier that goes from the spaces of
inputs to 0 1 and in the non strategic
setting the institution will evaluate
this according to their institutional
utility which is just the classification
accuracy are you between things that you
can change I'm just I'm trying to
understand this costs how should I think
that are you distinguishing here between
things that I can check that I can
change in the way that wants me to
change or things that I can change but
actually have no effect change or
anything here these things yes so here
that the cost is sort of agnostic to it
whether or not it's like gaming or
improvement change and so the model
doesn't really take this into account
and so I think that the argument before
is it most of the time when we're
deploying kind of solution concepts that
are based on this framework the costs
that you're changing here are more
likely to be gaming cost but like it's
not explicitly if there's no causal
model in the background that says if I
interviewed on this I'll change my label
so that's not really captured with this
can I assume that like the good changes
are more expensive than these gaming
changes so like these otherwise I would
just dude a good thing and you wouldn't
have any concerns maybe like like it's
possible I don't know I probably if I
thought about it maybe I could come up
with a clever example where that's not
true but I don't know yeah
and so it's okay so now it likes it so
now this is kind of a basic model in the
non-strategic case so in order to
account for strategic behavior we assume
or the institution and typically we'll
assume that the individual plays a best
response and so what the best response
looks like is that the individual
basically that takes or moves to a new
point X that maximizes some notion of
utility for the individual and here the
utility for the individual is a
difference of two terms on the one hand
it's the benefits of being classified in
a particular way at the new point and
then subtracted from this is the cost of
moving to this new point yes so what I
want to do here is I'm basically going
to say this is the model that the
institution assumes that the agents are
operating under when I move on to the
next part and I talk about the the
specific costs that might be imposed on
individuals I'm going to get away from
assuming that the individuals are best
responding but this is kind of like if
you're an institution and you deployed
like this Stackelberg this is what you
would use same thing mechanism design
you want to encourage the users to make
a change rather than discourage that
will make a change which
yes so I think I think one like I guess
maybe point part of the point of this
work is that maybe we should start
thinking about explicitly designing
interventions like this rather than just
assuming the cost function takes all
this into account but then the second
thing is that what kind of concomitant
with the idea that like you need to
reason causally about what are the
things that are lead to improvement
versus what are the things that kind of
are gaming like requires you just solve
probably a non-trivial kind of causal
inference problem which you might not
always be able to do in these I think
that's a really good direction is how
can you design classifiers and
incentivize good behavior I mean when I
saw a picture just seem like it's
creating a larger gap between that's
that's why I guess potentially another
critique of this type of approach to
solving this problem it's like maybe you
should use actually it's like
classifiers that it just incentivize
improvement or like maybe if you start
thinking about adjusting for strategic
behavior you actually triggered this arm
race in these dynamics and I think
that's another way to kind of critique
the solution concept
it's okay so we have this best response
and then basically the thing is that the
institution then is going to evaluate
their performance according to the
strategic utility which is basically
what's their classification accuracy if
they assume that the individual best
responds to the classifier that they're
playing and then the stackelberg
equilibrium is that the classifier that
maximizes is strict the strategic
utility okay so now I'm going to
introduce our model of the the social
burden that the the Stackelberg
equilibrium will kind of impose on
people that are being classified and I'm
gonna do this in two steps the first
step is I'm going to introduce what we
call the individual burden and so the
individual burden will just say it's the
minimum cost that an individual has to
incur in order to be classified
positively so if it's I guess it depends
on the specific classifier but it's kind
of a number of new credit cards you have
to open or the increase in net worth
you'd have to pay in order to get just
over the decision boundary and then now
that we've defined the individual burden
we're going to define the social burden
as the expected cost for positive
individuals to be classified positively
so this is just the expectation over the
individual burden but importantly we're
going to condition on the positive
individuals and I'm going to explain why
we do this in the next slide but for now
we should think about the social burden
is basically capturing the gaming costs
the positive individuals have to pay in
order to receive the correct outcome and
I guess we're explicit we're gonna be
interested in kind of a comparative
notion about how does this social burden
change between different points whether
it's a non-strategic optimum or the
Stackelberg equilibrium so this notion
of social burden is related to a number
of different kind of measures of costs
that have been proposed recently in the
the like fat star community and I'm
gonna go through a few of those in
illustrate kind of specific choices we
made in white and in designing the
social burden and then kind of discuss
what's going on there so the first thing
you want to compare to is the expected
cost of recourse which is introduced a
new Sun at all in 2019 and so here the
expected cost of your course is exactly
the same as a social burden with the
exception that they decided not to
condition on just the positive
individuals they do this over everybody
and I think I'm guess I'm gonna argue
why we should just think about the
positive individuals in two ways
so first is that I think I argued before
most of the time that we're dealing with
these kind of machine learning settings
that were the gaming or strategic
adaptation that you
is likely to be not improvement and so
negative individuals a game likely
aren't you become positive anyway so
like we're not gonna argue about whether
or not negative individuals should get a
thing but they're not really qualified
for but in some cases this can actually
lead to like long term harm and so if
the situation is very muddy in the case
of negative individuals whereas in the
case of positive individuals it's kind
of very salient but it's a
classification if they're qualified for
and this is an additional cost that
we're going to impose on them now we
could also consider as a permanent guard
due in 2019 the expected cost of
strategy so the difference here is that
rather than thinking about just the
burden they explicitly measure the
expected agent utility assuming that the
agent plays a best response and this
kind of gets to Josh's question is that
in our case we're not assuming that the
agent does makes any particular policy
or actually best responds instead we're
just saying like what's the minimum
distance that you have to travel and so
in this way we're kind of more robust to
agent model miss specification and we
can handle agents and think about the
social burden of like if agents don't
respond optimally or are perfect utility
maximizers
and sort of for a related analysis but
with slightly different quantities you
can also see who's nice paper from 2019
that thinks about false positive and
false negative rates okay so now that
we've had the kind of the formal
framework and our measure of costs and
institutional utility out of the way the
key question is how does institutional
utility trade-off against social burden
and before we do this I'm just gonna
mention kind of a slightly technical
lemma that we use to reduce the problem
from considering arbitrary classifiers
and like high dimensional feature spaces
and to just thinking about what
threshold classifiers and in particular
we're gonna think about classifiers that
are just thresholds on some likelihood
and so to recall will say that the
likelihood of a point X is basically
just the probability of being a true
positive if you have the feature values
X initially and the key assumption that
we're going to make is actually an
assumption on the cost function so we're
going to say that a cost function is
outcome monotonic if it satisfies two
somewhat natural properties the first is
that the cost to move to higher
likelihood points increases
monotonically with the likelihood so you
think about if you have a FICO score of
650 it's easier for you to move to a
point that has a FICO score of 680 then
it should move to a place with FICO
score of 720 and then the second thing
is that we're going to assume that
there's basically no cost to move
with lower likelihood so to go from 600
to 550 you don't have to pay anything so
if you have an outcome monotonic cost
the key thing the key lemma is that
every single every classifier has an
equivalent threshold classifier with the
same institutional utility and the same
social burden it's a threshold
classifier it just looks something like
this
basically you compute the likelihood for
your initial point you check is it
bigger than some threshold Pal if it is
you classify positively otherwise
classify negatively and so importantly
now like even though we started with
arbitrary classifiers and I Chi
dimensional input spaces now we can just
reason about what happens as we vary
this threshold Pal and so I'm gonna get
to our first main result which is
basically a trade-off between
institutional utility and social burden
and I'm going to start by characterizing
what the institutional utility looks
like as we vary this threshold cow on
the x-axis here so first we showed that
the institutional utility is quasi
concave function of the threshold so
it's monotonically increasing and to get
to the point that has maximum strategic
utility which is a stack of our
equilibrium and it's monotonically
decreasing after that I'm gonna call our
attention to two points on this curve
the first is the non strategic optimum
which is what the institution would play
if they didn't account for strategic
behavior then the other point is which
is I mentioned before the maximum of
this curve which is a Stackelberg
equilibrium and also we show that
basically the set of Nash equilibrium
will always fall in between these two
points on this curve ok so now that
we've characterized what the
institutional utility looks like the
next thing to do is think about what is
a social burden look like as a function
of this threshold but we show is that
the social burden is monotonically
increasing as a function of this
threshold so why does this matter what's
the upshot essentially what this says is
that any improvement in strategic
utility over the non strategic optimum
isn't free it's purchased at the price
of higher social burden and increased
gaming costs on positive individuals
so what's a takeaway from this like what
why is this important
well we think typically when we think
about strategic classification we're
usually only operating in one of the two
end points on this curve so typically
either we do nothing to account for
strategic behavior in which case with an
on strategic optimum or as soon as we
start accounting for strategy we go all
the way to the other end it would take a
completely institution center view and
if I choose a staff over equilibrium so
what we argue is that you should
probably think about actually more
richly exploring the space of trade-offs
in between these points of course the
choice of operating point is context
dependent but there's a number of
different reasons why you wouldn't
always choose even as an institution the
the Stackelberg equilibrium in this case
so one it's an institutional accuracy is
awfully loosely or even misspecified
objective for what you care about so it
might be the case that small accuracy
gains for the institution really don't
matter and if you consider the large
social burden that end up a potential 1%
increase requires maybe you choose a
different point on the curve it also
gives maybe some motivation for why we
should consider things like the Nash
equilibria instead of the Sacko burg
which is that the Nash equilibria always
has lower social burden than the
Stackelberg in this picture and maybe
some thinking back to the examples
before some of the green points that are
very close to the red points maybe I'm
ok with them having some cost because I
think you could probably extend like a
lot of the kind of analysis here to
handle a slightly more fine-grained
notions of cost or if you have different
types of individuals positive or not I
think right now this framework doesn't
explicitly include that because mostly
we just wanted to illustrate like the
high level trade-off but it seems like
that's a good direction
okay so now that we've talked about kind
of the trade-off on the one hand between
institutional utility and social burden
on the other I think it's it's also
natural to consider how increases in
social burden might also elicit fairness
concerns and in particular if we're
increasing social burden by choosing
increase at higher points that have
higher strategic utility its natural to
ask how was the social burden
distributed across subpopulations
and so just a percent that's kind of as
cleanly as possible I'm going to first
describe a measure of unequal burden and
the case where we just have two distinct
subpopulations so we're going to think
about having an advantage group Group A
on the one hand and on the other hand a
disadvantaged group Group B on the other
and I'm going to define a measure of the
unequal burden that falls on these two
different groups which we call the
social gap and essentially the social
gap is just a social burden that would
fall on members of Group B so the
expected burden of positive individuals
from group B minus the social burden it
would fall on members of group A and I'm
gonna talk about two different ways in
which we handle or think about weight
ways in which members of Group A or
group B to be disadvantaged so the first
way that we think about disadvantage is
what we call disadvantage in features
essentially we say that group A is this
adversary Group B is disadvantaged in
features with respect to Group A if
individuals positive individuals from
group B have systematically lower
outcome likelihoods than group A so you
should think of this as kind of a
systematic measurement bias so if we're
gonna summarize this in terms of like
the CDF's of their likelihoods it would
look something like this follows that if
you look at the positive individuals
from group B they always have higher
likelihoods than individuals from Group
A and to make this slightly more
concrete I'll use an example from
lending where if on the x-axis here I'm
going to plot like a normalized version
of a FICO score and on the y-axis I'm
just going to plot what's the plot of
the cdf of positive individuals from
each group and what you can see is it
for every single level of FICO score
that white individuals have like the CDF
for black individuals is higher than the
CDF for white individuals so the way to
interpret this is you can imagine that
among individuals that are going to
repay the distribution for black
individuals is shifted to towards lower
FICO scores then
the distribution for white individuals
and so consequently you should imagine
if you raise the threshold a little bit
like all those individuals have further
to go and have to incur probably a
higher cost in order to cross the
threshold
so the next way that I'm going to even
like those scores
yeah not sure so yeah I think I guess
this is basically the condition and then
this is that from like it's like a
calibrated focus we're just from like an
actual FICO score exactly yes so then
the second way that we're gonna think
about disadvantage and this is maybe
it's even more natural it's what we'll
call disadvantage and cost so we'll say
that individuals from Group B are
disadvantaged and costs relative to
group A if they just experienced higher
manipulation costs than people from
Group A and this is very similar to the
analysis and who at all in 2019 so kind
of for every point x and y the costs in
group b is higher than a cost in group a
and there's a litany of different
reasons why you could experience like
higher costs from different groups and
i'm gonna illustrate too and there's a
bunch more examples in our paper so the
first one is you can imagine that
there's economic differences between
those two subgroups so you should think
about the example of college admissions
so that families with means have had
access that pest prep services better
extracurriculars maybe even sailing
coaches that let them like more easily
access higher education institutions the
second thing you might think about is
something like information asymmetry and
so to refer to the example at the
beginning of that talk about social
program eligibility in colombia is that
families with political connections or
who closer to the officials that are
actually deciding whether like
implementing the procedure and can tell
them about what exactly is in the score
and how exactly these scores are
calculated might find it significantly
easier to manipulate them than
individuals without then there's I guess
a variety of other reasons why you might
be able to experience different costs
across the two different groups so
what's the key result and in order to
explain the result I'm gonna return to
our image that we have before of social
burden against institutional utility so
as before you have institutional utility
and social burden which is monotonically
increasing as a function of the
threshold and now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to plot this quantity the
social adapt quantity again as a
function of the threshold what we can
show is that the social gap is also
monotonically increasing in the
threshold so the way that you should
interpret this is that increases over
the non-strategic optimum 1 are
purchased at the expense of higher
social burden but if you then you'd go
further and break down well where is
this burden falling react
show that the burden falls
disproportionately on members from the
disadvantaged group as you continue to
move the threshold higher and higher so
this should also elicit sort of fairness
concerns in addition to just the general
concern about kind of a higher social
burden in the population now if you
model the disadvantaged group in your
model so these are both this is for
either the disadvantaged in features for
disadvantaged and costs so kind of the
intuition for the disadvantaged in
features is that you can imagine if
individuals from the disadvantaged
Cooper's but positive individuals have
systematically lower scores then as you
continue to raise the threshold like the
distance that they have to travel to get
the threshold gets higher and higher
relative to people that are initially
close to the threshold exactly which is
a property both of the distribution and
also the initial deployed predictors I
guess so I guess it's it's kind of
agnostic as to where you start on this
curve so this is true for every single
point on the like every single tile
basically as you vary the threshold but
I think the important point is yet where
do you start and then where would you go
to afterwards if you want to make it
more robust to strategically be here
great okay so what's the upshot of all
this normally in strategic
classification we take a very
institutional's an institution centric
view we think mostly about designing
classifiers that have as high of
institutional accuracy as possible
what we want to do in our work is
basically argue that this increase in
institutional accuracy isn't free it
comes to the human cost in particular it
comes at a higher human cost in terms of
higher social burden and this burden
moreover is disproportionately falls on
disadvantaged groups so what I think we
need more of is we need more of not just
understanding how to build machine
learning models that are robust to
adversarial strategic behavior but
thinking about the ways in which those
models affect the people who adapt to
those models and both and thinking about
the big cost that that imposes kind of
broadly on the population with that I
want to thank my collaborators
sniffing Millinocket are going and where
it's hard yes negative externalities
would probably like more common than
positive externalities but did you did
you wait try and like do a similar
analysis for positive externalities like
if if something is actually a causal
feature right there's a positive
externality to getting everybody on
their business that presumably is just
measured in terms of you know lower
insurance yes I think that's a really
interesting direction which is that
basically like typically in the
strategic classification literature
there's this kind of monolithic view on
the costs and the features are taken as
given and there's no sort of causal
model in the background and I think what
I want to argue is that if we want to
start thinking about the positive
externalities explicitly we need to
start reasoning more about the causal
models in the way in which I'm changing
your features also subsequently changes
the labels downstream and to build that
into it like into a kind of a complete
picture on both at the same time so I
don't think that's something that the
models explicitly handle right now but a
really interesting way to improve a lot
of the strategic classification work
their agency we get some intuition on
the whole cup work on why like most
machine learning algorithm to come up
with a console features is that I think
it's about the same supervised learning
right the same supported learning was in
the anti causal direction and not in the
coastal directions it's a collection of
examples and what can also come up with
examples that go the other way it's not
like I'm just guessing but it's not so
much about the algorithms about the data
and my gift in the data in the first
place there's a lot of features which
are like just cause I did and the
awkwardness with that's what it is about
the data this is first a cosmos features
are like harder to measure or more
expensive to measure have any most
likley like most the time I think that
the true causal thing so you want to
measure might not even like be lazy you
can measure there's maybe like someone's
like creditworthiness is not something
you can you'll say yeah maybe there's
something up the street yeah and so most
of the time we're kind of measuring like
downstream
but like your dungeon foxy can be more
efficient to manipulate
so we'll start today - earlier plans we